Speaker 1: Over the years, we've seen plenty of
right wing politicians sully whatever credibility
they had left trying to get into the good graces
of Donald Trump. And oftentimes it ends up just
completely backfiring, or they get into trouble
over it. And the next person to be following this
trend appears to be Trump's fourth and final
White House chief of Staff Mark Meadows. And
that is because Meadows is no longer cooperating
with the January 6th Congressional Committee,
meaning that if his obstinance continues,
charges could indeed be coming his way.
Now, as recently as a few weeks ago, Meadows was
cooperating with the January 6th committee. He
was providing them with documents and really
naming names like the whole reason we know
about the story having to do with Sean Hannity
and Brian Kilmeade and Laura Ingraham. Urging
Meadows to tell Trump to end the insurrection
was because Meadows was willing to hand over
the documents. He was willing to hand over
those text messages to the committee. Obviously,
we also found out that Todd Jr. was trying
to urge Meadows to put an end to it.
And we also found out that Congressman Jim Jordan
was giving an outline to Meadows as to how Mike
Pence could throw out the Electoral College votes
in states that they were contesting. So this is
all based on the fact that Meadows was complying
with the committee's requests and handing over the
documents. But everything changed around the time
Meadows released his book. The Chiefs chief and
Trump publicly lambasted Meadows for the claim,
specifically that Trump exposed people to COVID
after he tested positive for the virus. And one
of those people that he exposed was actually Joe
Biden during their first debate. Trump called the
allegation fake news, and Meadows backtracked,
saying, Oh yeah, that part of my book that was
fake news. Apparently regretting that he upset his
former boss, Meadows thought that the book
was going to flatter Trump and instead
it mainly just got under his skin because of the
media coverage having to do with that positive
test that did the exact opposite of what he was
trying to do. It was right after this incident
that Meadows halted his communications with the
Jan. six committee. The Jan. six commission wanted
to get Meadows to show up in person for testimony.
Meadows lawyer, George Terwilliger, argued he had
done enough. He had provided the documents, and
the committee should be satisfied with that.
In fact, Terwilliger released a statement
that reads quote The select committee is true.
Intentions in dealing with Mr. Meadows have been
revealed when it accuses him of contempt, citing
the very documents his cooperation has produced.
So what Mark Meadows attorney is saying here is
that basically you should be grateful to my client
because so much of this information that you have
now is because he was willing to cooperate with
the investigation. You shouldn't be turning around
now and trying to rope him into testifying if
he doesn't want to. He shouldn't be threatening
him with criminal charges because, you know,
he's given you so much already. And it is true
that Mark Meadows was fully cooperating and handed
over 9000 pages of documents. Even though some of
that information was indeed damaging to Meadows
and to the former president, he still did do that.
But you don't really get partial credit when
you're talking about a select committee that
has the rule of law behind them. And if you're
not going to do everything that they ask of you,
then you're going to open yourself up to criminal
exposure. And that's exactly what's happened here.
Recently, the House voted to refer. Mark Meadows
for criminal contempt of Congress charges.
And it's going to be up to Biden's Justice
Department and Attorney General Merrick Garland
to decide whether or not he's actually going to
be charged and if he is and he's found guilty.
There's actually the possibility on the table of
Mark Meadows serving prison time over this now.
Is that actually going to happen? I don't
know. He may not even get charged in the
first place because it's going to be seen as
an overtly political act if this happens. Like,
yes, Bannon was charged in this investigation,
but he also wasn't willing to comply at all.
And Bannon was in Trump's administration, but
only as an adviser, whereas Mark Meadows like
he was the chief of staff. After all, it's a much
more important gig. And so maybe they would just
figure that Biden and Biden's Justice Department
wouldn't have the political capital to charge.
Mark Meadows for his obstinance in this case, but
we'll have to wait and see. And then obviously,
if he does get charged, it doesn't mean
necessarily he'll get convicted. And if he
does get convicted, that doesn't mean necessarily
that he'll go to prison over it. He may just
face a fine or something like that. So we'll have
to wait and see what happens. But you never know
like this could definitely happen. And there's
definitely some legal exposure here. And Meadows,
I'm sure, is probably not sleeping very well
at night these days. And that's all because of
Donald Trump. And he was trying to get on Trump's
good side. And now at the end of the day, he's not
only on Trump's bad side, he's also running the
risk of criminal charges. So that's Mark Meadows
for you. And now there's this very, very long list
of people who went down for. Donald Trump, sake,
you already thought it was long enough. Well,
it's getting even longer. We have people on there
like Roger Stone, Steve Bannon, Paul Manafort,
Michael Flynn, Rick Gates, George Papadopoulos,
Michael Cohen. We know that Rudy Giuliani, of
course, is in trouble. He's under investigation,
and he's also facing that civil suit with
Dominion Voting Systems. There's people like
Mike Lindell and Sidney Powell, who are also
running against that case with Dominion Voting
Systems. So is Mark Meadows the next to follow,
the next to get in trouble trying to get into
the good graces of Donald Trump? We'll just have
to wait and see. But you think that all of these
people would learn their lesson by now on the
bonus show? Today, we have some great stories.
We're going to talk about how Kim Potter, the
former police officer she has been found guilty
in manslaughter charges having to do with the
killing of Daunte Wright. Kim Potter, of course,
was the officer who confused her service weapon
with her Taser, and she thought that she was
tasing Daunte Wright, but she actually shot and
killed him. She has been found guilty now, so
we'll see what happens with sentencing. We'll see
the reactions to all of that. We're going to talk
about Donald Trump declaring victory on the War
on Christmas. You talked to Mike Huckabee about
how before Trump was president, no one would say,
Merry Christmas, and you weren't allowed to. But
ever since Trump served in office, now, all
of a sudden you can say, Merry Christmas,
and I also want to talk about a recent COVID
scare that I had. I think many of you will find
that story interesting. If you want to watch The
Boehner show today, go to join Pacman dot com and
sign up for a membership. Or you can go
to Patriot CNN.com slash David Pakman show
and sign up for a $5 membership there. That's
going to do it for today. It's going to do it
for the week. Merry Christmas to everyone. David
will be back next week and we'll see you then.